[Música]
[Aplausos]
nació en la ciudad de mexico en el año
de 1973
crecí con mi abuela materna ya que mi
madre decidió vivir en eeuu y mi padre
tenía otra familia
mis hermanos todos los días de mi vida
me violentaban me agredían recuerdo
cuando tenía ocho años mi hermano llegó
una noche alcoholizado me levanto a
golpes y me dejo mis espinillas marcadas
con sus botas vaqueras
la violencias y su extrema justo cuando
cumplí nueve años
mi abuela falleció y aunque en ocasiones
ella se metía en medio de las peleas en
ese momento ella ya no estaba
yo me sentí sola y un día decidí salir
salir a caminar ya distraerme
en busca de algún momento de felicidad
encontré a un amigo de mi abuela
pidiéndole que me ayudara a encontrar
trabajo porque mis hermanos ya no se
preocupaban ni siquiera por alimentarme
gracias a eso logre solventar mis gastos
pero eso duró muy poco tiempo
una de mis hermanas me lo empezaba a
quitar
hasta que un día decidí caminar por las
calles del centro histórico exactamente
en balderas y juárez llegué me senté en
una banca y esa tarde decidí que jamás
regresaría a mi casa
justo me cayó la noche y a lo lejos vi
la silueta de una mujer femenina yo no
sabía que era una mujer trans pero en
ese momento me identifique
inmediatamente con ella
así que inmediatamente me acerco y le
pido que me ayude a arreglarme como ella
ella volteo muy seria y me dijo ponte a
trabajar háblale a los carros te
llevarán al hotel
pero cobrarles 400 pesos fue lo que hice
le hablé a un carro se paró y en cuanto
me subí a bordo del vehículo en ese
momento yo le explicaba toda la
violencia que vivía en mi casa
pidiéndole que me llevara con él él me
dijo que no podría que si me llevaría
con él se metería en un problema legal
pero también me dijo que no desanimará
que él me pagaría una semana de hotel y
que me dejaría el dinero suficiente para
que yo me pudiera alimentar en lo que
encontraba un trabajo y así fue
tuvimos relaciones y el muchacho se fue
y ese fue mi primer cliente de trabajo
sexual a los 9 años
al día siguiente
[Aplausos]
me levanta la muchacha del aseo del
hotel en ese momento me pidió que
saliera de la habitación para que
hiciera el aseo quienes aún esperan yo
caminé por los pasillos cuando me
encontré a dos mujeres trans y me
percaté que en el hotel vivían
mujeres trans trabajadoras sexuales en
cuanto vi a viridiana y a la chavela les
pedí que me ayudara a arreglarme como
ella
ellas voltearon y me dijeron traes
dinero e inmediatamente les mostré el
dinero que el cliente me había dado así
que me llevaron al centro me compraron
pelucas zapatillas pestañas maquillajes
y al regresar al hotel me empezaron a
arreglar me dijeron que será la primera
y la única vez que me arreglaban si yo
lo aprendía por pendeja
así que yo observé atentamente en el
espejo todo el proceso que se llevó para
que me arreglarán yo estaba feliz en ese
momento no podía creer que por primera
vez me estaba viendo como una mujer como
esa mujer en la cual yo me identificaba
así que al terminar de arreglarme ellas
fueron a su habitación también a
arreglarse
al regresar me dijeron que nos fuéramos
a trabajar así que me llevaron a la
avenida de insurgentes y álvaro obregón
en esa esquina me presentaron con la
madrota para explicarme cuál iba a ser
mi cuota diaria que tendría que pagar
para trabajar en ese lugar
los primeros días y los primeros meses
fue algo muy bonito me fue muy bien en
el trabajo a la mejor porque era una
niña de nueve años les gustaba mucho a
los clientes
pero una de las primeras demandas que
tuve como trabajadora sexual fue el uso
y consumo de drogas los clientes me
pedían que consumiera con ellos con la
condición de contratarme
el consumo al principio era esporádico
después fue aumentando al grado que me
llevó a estar en una condición de calle
llena de costras de mugre limpiando
parabrisas en una esquina pidiendo
limosnas en la calle para poder seguir
consumiendo mi droga
fueron muchos años los que yo consumido
más de 15
en ese proceso cuando tenía 13 años
recuerdo fue cuando me detectaron vih
yo me quería morir en las drogas me
quería perder pone en algún momento deje
de defender mi transición deje de
defender mi lucha por vivir y por
continuar saliendo adelante
en una de tantas ocasiones que yo me
drogué me metí a esos departamentos que
estaban en tepito donde nos vendían la
droga y nos dejaban consumir
un día uno de esos días llegó el
operativo de la policía federal nos
ordenaron que nos tirábamos todos al
suelo yo obedecí pero la chica que
vendía la droga me aventó la bolsa de
mercancía al lado mío y me llevaron
presa
estuve presente santa martha acatitla
durante diez años ocho meses siete días
hasta que conseguí mi libertad y
conseguí mi inocencia porque yo era
inocente y lo logré comprobar y gracias
a eso me dieron totalmente absolución
del caso
[Aplausos]
justo el 30 de septiembre del 2016
mi vida dio un giro
total
aproximadamente eran las 10 de la noche
cuando yo me dirigía hacia el trabajo
sexual en puente de alvarado
era una noche fría y en el trayecto
de chimalhuacán al metro pantitlán tenía
que abordar una combi en la cual yo iba
sola en ese momento me entró un
sentimiento de nostalgia y de
arrepentimiento y le pedí a dios que me
perdonara por todos mis pecados y que
abre en llanto
fueron más de dos horas de trayecto
hasta que llegue a puente de alvarado y
justo cuando llegó me encuentro con
pagola buenrostro una compañera
en cuanto a la vi le llamen la atención
porque se había comportado muy agresiva
con otra compañera ella volteó y me dijo
no hay que pelear esta noche está triste
y yo le respondí sí claro está triste
porque no has tomado tuanis ya que el
anís nos ayuda a calmar el dolor de los
tacones y a calmar el frío de las
madrugadas
en ese momento me sonrió tomamos un taxi
y nos fuimos a comprar el anís al
regresar ya que nos acompañaron tres
compañeras más ellas bajan del auto y
paola voltea y me dice salud y brinde
con ella
cuando volteamos ya estaba a un cliente
solicitando servicios de mis otras
compañeras ellas lo batieron después se
acercó conmigo en ese momento me percaté
que era de un que un cliente de esos que
nosotras le llamamos piojos
piojos porque traía los pantalones a las
rodillas venía alcoholizado y se venía
abusando de que ya lo hayan conectado a
los policías y únicamente quería pagar
200 pesos yo lo rechacé
cuando me volteo enseguida aborda paola
paola se voltea después de hablar con él
y nos avienta el cabello diciéndonos ya
me voy a trabajar perras y se subió al
carro
justo cuando avanzó el carro unos
cuantos metros escuché unos gritos de
auxilio que gritaban mi nombre kenia
kenia kenia yo corría el vehículo y
justo cuando me paré en la ventanilla
del copiloto escuché dos detonaciones de
arma de fuego
mi compañera se desvaneció en los brazos
de aquel hombre en lo que él aventaba su
cuerpo desvanecido al asiento del
copiloto
yo me quedé muda no pude hablar me quedé
impactada
este sujeto se me quedó viendo fijamente
a los ojos me apuntó con su arma y
disparó
gracias a dios el arma se encasquilló no
salió la bala en ese momento corrí para
detener el auto y cuando volteé ya
estaba una patrulla donde lo detienen en
fragancia con el arma en la mano y mi
amiga agonizando en el vehículo
inmediatamente llegaron agentes del
ministerio público para que rindiera mos
nuestra declaración donde en todo
momento decía yo ser testigo del caso y
en todo momento también decidieron
invisibilizar me diciendo que yo era una
curiosa del lugar una tipificación que
ni siquiera existe
espere más de 48 horas afuera de la
alcaldía cuauhtémoc esperando alguna
noticia respecto qué iba a pasar con
este sujeto todo el tiempo se me negó
cualquier tipo de información alegando
que yo no era ni ni un familiar de paola
justo cuando llegó la hora de la
audiencia oral
yo llegué me presenté
pero el juez y el ministerio público me
invitaron a salir de la sala para que no
la contaminar y al final de esa
audiencia ellos decidieron dejarlo en
libertad
en ese momento mis compañeras querían
destrozar las instalaciones de los
juzgados yo calmen los ánimos y les
argumento que teníamos que ir por paola
porque todavía estaba en un congelador
esperando a que fuéramos por ella
el cual solicite su cuerpo ante el
fiscal y el fiscal rotundamente me dio
uno de respuesta me dijo que yo no era
nada de familia de ella y que no me la
podía entregar así que me vi en la
necesidad de amenazar a ese fiscal y le
dije que si no me entregaba mi compañera
aunque ya habían dejado a su homicida
libre yo le iba a parar insurgentes con
500 chicas trabajadoras sexuales e
inmediatamente y por arte de magia
decidieron entregarme el cuerpo
después de dos noches de velación y
vamos rumbo al panteón
en ese momento decidí que iba a llevar a
paola exactamente en el lugar donde la
asesinaron
para darle una guardia de honor y
despedirla como la mujer que era
cuando alguien me dijo una compañera
kenia si vas a hacer tú desmadre hazlo
bien
claro así que le pedí al de la carroza
que se adelantará hasta la avenida de
los insurgentes
rotundamente me dijo no no puedo pasar
hasta allá si tú quieres te bajas si
hace esto es papá pero yo no me puedo
parar en medio
justo en ese momento nos agarró el alto
y yo aproveché para quitarle a las
llaves de la carroza
me bajé de la carroza bajé el ataúd de
mi compañera y en medio de insurgentes
le grite a las autoridades y al mundo
que nos estaban matando
que a nadie le importaba porque
únicamente nosotras somos mujeres trans
trabajadoras sexuales nos discriminan
nos violentan nos arrebatan nuestros
derechos humanos como si fuera un balde
de agua
yo ya estaba cansada
no sabía cómo gritarle al mundo toda
esta situación
así que en ese momento
decidimos gritarlo todas mis compañeras
y yo
en méxico
ocupa a nivel mundial el segundo lugar
en crímenes de odio
el 65% de estos crímenes son cometidos
con mujeres trans trabajadoras sexuales
y aunque muchos quisieran vernos
afuera
no nos quisieran identificar
yo nunca me voy a callar
a pesar de todo lo que he vivido
ya pesar de que mi activismo me ha
puesto en peligro y estoy amenazada de
muerte y tengo que vivir todos los días
de mi vida con una escolta personalizada
no lograrán callarme
yo le prometí a paola esta tarde que la
enterramos que jamás descansaría hasta
que agarrara su asesino
porque para méxico y para toda la
sociedad no importamos únicamente cuando
está en esas notas rojas
qué dicen
hombre asesina a martillazos a través
aquí tenemos una nota también
periodística de cómo nos se expresan de
nuestra integridad aún después de muerta
nos siguen asesinando
no siguen violentando no sigan
discriminando y nos siguen
invisibilizando
escalofriante hallazgo aparece cadáver
de transexual torturado y baleado
y así puedo seguir me toda la noche con
todas esas notas amarillistas que no
tienen ni la mínima sensibilidad de
transmitir lo que sufrimos nosotros
no lograrán callar mis compañeros
yo sé que la lucha no es fácil ni lo
será
pero hace más de dos años logré
constituir una base que se llama casa de
las muñecas tirésias el nombre de mi
compañera paola y estoy a punto de
inaugurar el primer albergue para
mujeres trans en la ciudad de mexico
estos crímenes de odio me han arrebatado
a mis mejores amigas
y también a causa del vih pero y le
gritó al mundo
que mi venganza será que seamos felices
salud por todas ellas
[Aplausos]
[Música]